morgen ist ja ein besonderer tag in der
pandemie geschichte da wird dieser
sogenannte evaluationsbericht
vorgestellt das heißt experten oder
regierung ausgewählte experten haben
sich die diversen massnahmen angeschaut
und geprüft welche viel gebracht haben
die lok downs die masken die
schulschließung was hat was gebracht und
was nicht
dieser bericht wird schon heftig
kritisiert bevor ihr überhaupt
irgendeine gelesen hat da herr
lauterbach scheint für diese evaluation
angst zu haben wie der teufel vor dem
weihwasser es gibt mittlerweile ja auch
ein
hashtag der heißt wir wollen masken
pflicht der es gibt eine in der
gesellschaft ein willen bei vielen gar
nicht so wenigen auf keinen fall aus
dieser pandemie irgendwie raus zu
gleiten ja herr montgomery der
ärztefunktionär ist auch so ein fall und
zwar das ist das erstaunliche relativ
unabhängig von der lage in der man sich
befindet wie die lage im herbst und
winter sein wird kann niemand wissen es
ist unbekanntes gelände wie die zukunft
im allgemeinen wie ist die lage heute
die lage heute bedeutet ist sieht so aus
dass von einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems und intensivstationen
keine rede sein kann damit ersparen wir
nicht widersprechen und dass die
inzidenz
infektionszahlen nicht mehr die
bedeutung haben diese zu beginn der
pandemie hatten weil wir es mit einem in
der regel in der regel milden verlauf zu
tun habe das ändert nichts daran dass
man risikogruppen soll spielt menschen
in altenheim besonders schützen muss
aber insgesamt ist die gefahrenlage doch
eine andere als sie am anfang gewesen
ist und mein eindruck ist und da finde
ich sollte man wachsam sein er sollte
die gesellschaften wirklich aufpassen
dass man uns in einen dritten corona
winter hinein also geistig gesehen ihn
einprügeln möchte
obwohl das die reale lage möglicherweise
gar nicht hergibt ich sage dazu um nicht
missverstanden zu werden wenn
übermorgen eine gefährlichere variante
um die ecke biegt oder wenn tatsächlich
die
intensivstation wieder voll auf muss man
natürlich völlig neu nachdenken dann
muss man was machen ich bin ja nicht
gegenmaßnahmen aber ich bin dagegen und
ich bin dreimal geimpft und alles ich
habe alles mitgemacht und zwar aus
überzeugung jetzt nicht ungefährt nicht
nicht weil man irgendwelchen druck auf
mich ausgeübt hätte hat niemand
aber
wenn wir
freiheitsrechte kassieren wenn wir das
leben der leute regulieren man kann das
machen aber man muss triftige gründe
dafür haben finde ich es muss gründe
dafür geben man kann das nicht mal
daumen oder aus dem bauchgefühl heraus
machen und diesen diesen eindruck habe
ich im moment wir haben
in deutschland und also ich muss wieder
auf deutschland zu sprechen kommen also
offensichtlich ein größeres angst und
panik potenzial als anderswo also und
ich höre ja auch wenn ich das radio oder
fernseher anschalte ja auch pausenlos
ein panikorchester spielen ja ich und in
unseren nachbarländern sieht es halt
doch vielleicht mentalitätsmäßig ein
bisschen anders aus ich bin kürzlich mit
der eisenbahn nach holland gefahren sie
glauben gar nicht wie sich das leben
verändert sobald sie die niederländische
grenze überschritten haben in den bussen
und u bahnen keine maske pflicht in den
zügen keine massen glauben sie die rolle
der wollen aussterben sind die alle
irgendwie suizid gefährdet oder sind sie
alle blöde ich glaube nicht
anderes naturell
aber in anderen händen dänemark
tschechien da bin ich auch gewesen ich
habe ein paar mal so zu sagen wie landes
das land verlassen ja immer legal und
und da ist es eben da ist die stimmung
einfach eine etwas andere ich will das
jetzt gar nicht groß kritisieren ich
will nur sagen damit komme ich zum dass
wir wirklich aufpassen müssen dass wir
nicht ohne wirklich überzeugende gründe
in diesem in diesem diesen dritten
corona winter hinein getrieben werden
folge arbeit würden dass die bürger denn
überhaupt noch mitmachen kronawetter
schwer zu sagen aber ich finde auch wie
er schon sagt wir dürfen nicht so viel
panikmache wir dürfen die leute nicht so
trennen also ich so möchte ich mir jetzt
gerade auf deutschlandtournee und wir
haben sehr strenge krone regeln und wir
müssen nun mal die maske den ganzen tag
tragen was ich auch gerne mache also ob
es nicht gibt oder nicht ich würde
trotzdem eine maske tragen und ich werde
aber ganz schief von den leuten
angeguckt und dann gibt es wirklich zwei
seiten und die einzelteile für diese
maßnahmen und die anderen gehen und es
wird die ganzheitliche auch da wo ich
jetzt wohne in balingen sind die vier
querdenker und man merkt schon wie die
leute so so aggressiv untereinander sind
wie die bürger untereinander aber ich
denke schon dass heute viel natürlich
mit der presse aber auch mit der politik
zu tun weil die stacheln ist auch schon
die ganze zeit an und man hört halt
wirklich nur dieses eine thema oder
corona jetzt der krieg und weltkriege es
gibt eigentlich nur probleme und
deswegen möchte ich unbedingt in der
veranstaltungsbranche meine shows machen
damit ich die leute sich auf andere
gedanken bringen und ich hoffe dass ich
das dann auch davon oktober meinen
eigenen shows machen weil ja die leute
sind müde und man sieht ja auch diese
ganzen konzerte die jetzt alle
stattfinden die leute wollen raus die
wollen endlich aufhören diese ganzen
sorgen zu haben und wir haben einfach
gerade sehr viele probleme und ich hoffe
dass die politik da helfen kann
weil ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich
verstehe nicht so viel von politik und
deswegen gebe ich eigentlich auch wie
gesagt mit vertrauen meine stimme an die
politik und hoffe dass sie es besser
machen aber gerade läuft ein sehr viel
falsch und ja wir hoffen einfach dass
alles besser wird aber ich habe ja schon
gesagt wir werden ab morgen darüber
diskutieren das kommt sicherlich auch
dazu wie die einzelnen maßnahmen zu
bewerten waren und ich kann nur sagen
dass wir die position der fdp auch
während der korona zeit und gerade jetzt
auch in den letzten
monaten dass wir keine freiheits
eingriffe mehr zulassen werden weil es
nur weil es der einfachste weg ist aber
es gibt auch andere themen wie
spritpreise oder die erhöhten
kosten der im lebensmittel die fdp hat
ja auch zweig mitgetragen beispielsweise
die ausgaben sind im winter wir haben am
ende des tages
das ist richtig eine abwägung getroffen
aber man muss ja mal sagen weswegen war
dies noch nötig und deswegen
haben wir glaube ich schon dafür gesorgt
dass eine reihe von maßnahmen zunächst
erstmal in der möglichkeit die wir als
oppositionsfraktion seinerzeit hatten
parlamentsbeteiligung et cetera in die
richtige richtung gegangen ist und dass
wir in diesen letzten winter so
reingegangen sind das wie gesagt liegt
ein stück weiter daran dass wir den
regierungswechsel im auch erst im anfang
dezember hatten ja eine bundestagswahl
ende september
wir hätten sicherlich auch andere
konstellationen
das ist ja klar werden lieber jamaica
verhandelt dazu war die cdu leider
hätten eigentlich nicht leider leider
mit herr spahn hätten werden die union
schon auf den richtigen weg gebracht
nach den vergangenen 16 jahren aber
unabhängig davon
der letzte winter war in den letzten
jahren war die union ja nicht einmal
eine letzte der letzte winter der letzte
winter war ein abbild der situation wie
wir das land vorgefunden haben und ich
kann die nur garantieren dass wir das
jetzt im kommenden herbst und damit dann
auch in vororten auf dem winter so selig
dreimal sie
das kind doch gar nicht das gefühl dass
wir so ein paar landesregierung ich
meine dass jetzt alles vorbei weil
manchen landes regierungsbeteiligung
aber sie haben ja
sie machen das schon alles richtig
eindruck davon wie man so ganz so als
hätte man mit allen nix tore machen
ich glaube dass die letzten 16 jahre
durch und gar keine verantwortung
natürlich land allein aber wenn sie sich
die parlamentsreden von ihnen in ihren
kollegen angucken hat man wohl das
gefühl wir müssen
zwei dinge unterscheiden ja das eine ist
die frage der letzten 16 jahre die
übrigens alles in allem ich meine wir
hatten die letzten längste
wirtschaftswachstums zeit in der
geschichte was haben sie daraus gemacht
warten sie mal kurz in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik viele erwerbstätige
wie nie zuvor wir hatten
haushaltsüberschüsse hat bei
fdp-regierungsbeteiligung schon lange
nicht mehr gegeben haushaltsüberschüsse
sozialversicherungen stabil das waren
schon auch viele viele gute jahre
trotzdem jahr gibt es auch themen die zu
starke abhängigkeit von russland
überhaupt gar keine frage dass wir da
einige übrigens vieles ist 2000 rigid
arisierung des 2009 bis 3 sind auch mal
wir haben alle eine verantwortung mit
aber es gibt zwei dinge zu trennen aus
meiner sicht das eine ist die frage
warum sind wir in der situation in der
wir jetzt sind und der debatte stelle
ich mich auch gern und auch
selbstkritisch die andere frage ist was
passiert in der krise im krisen
management seit 34 monaten seit
kriegsbeginn hohe energiepreise was ist
mit der frage der vorbereitung für den
winter unter die beiden fragen muss man
trennen und was ihr ja da versucht in
jeder debatte und im zweifel ja auch sie
gerade schon wieder damit angefangen
haben ist ja ihr wollt die debatte über
das krisenmanagement und die probleme
die es auch da gibt es ein paar fragen
habe ich da jedenfalls auch die wollte
immer beenden mit dem hinweis darauf
dass das doch die letzten tests neuer
regierungspartner übrigens in den
letzten 16 jahren zwölf jahre mitregiert
hat ist ja dann irgendwie auch noch teil
der geschichte deswegen stellen wir uns
und ich stelle mich da auch jeder
diskussion überhaupt gar kein gar keine
frage schon der frage